hey what's up
names Gregory Gregory the Alba Caroline
gifts and Nels is here with me today the
lovely Caroline she's a girl and I for
my understanding she has never she has
written on train before I have what I
like once or twice oh yeah and what do
you know this movie from Universal
Pictures the girl on the train no segue
that quick whoa this trailer has a lot
of views based on a book I think a lot
books a lot to read them words that's
the problem isn't it would you go grab
some food a teacher once told me I was
the mistress of self reinvention nice
whoa it's like having a secret Oh
and nobody but me knows I'm doing it
right
oh my god okay so I still have from the
Train
she was she was with this man
just for a second
is this her
can you tell me how are you work Friday
night I was in the city and then I went
to visit my husband you mean your
ex-husband it's my understanding that
the woman who was gone missing who is
his nanny I need you to stay away
so what did you do during those hours at
night I don't remember
just in time missing
Oh what happened tell me the truth no
I'm sure that we were seen in the area
that night
did you murder Megan Hipwell
I'm not the girl I used to be
we know that gets you thank you huh
I love missing-person movies like I like
Gone Baby Gone I liked a gone girl like
the movie ransom it's cool because it
like there's a lot more psychological
factors at play here than just someone
gone missing cuz it does make you wonder
like what is Emily Blunt you know like
I've seen the split personality twist
I'm like a billion times but it makes
you wonder like what if she is have a
little split personality and she did
kill her and I love Emily Blunt
fantastic actress there's a lot of great
actors in here actually
Billy Bennet's like in everything now
man hailey Bennet's really working a lot
and she's a very attractive lady
and I'm wonderfully talented actress put
the two together you got an awesome
person to watch on screen no that's my
mother coke you were doing earlier I
need to do why I actually have funny you
could also go for like three days which
is fine that you bring that up though
because I have a scene that I do cocaine
cocaine
really really well if you want to go for
like method realistic approach I know a
guy so it's totally cool thank you
and the Rebecca Ferguson wasn't it which
this is cool because Emily Blunt was an
edge of tomorrow with Tom Cruise and she
was a badass female lead and then
Rebecca Ferguson was in Mission
Impossible rogue nation where she was
the badass female lead now that are here
together for this mystery thriller hell
yeah Madden Emily Blunt seems a little
crazy yeah now she does nobody mean like
a real Emily Blunt were like No
character character of Rachel Watson
yeah Emily Blunt yeah that's the whole
point is that she does look a little
crazy were supposed to anticipate you
know whether or not she did it you know
that's the point yeah I mean hey I
didn't mean it like that
Caroline please I wasn't trying to be
better than you I do it naturally Justin
Theroux who's in there
Jennifer Aniston's hubby yeah he's a
good-looking one that guy he what I like
about this is I feel like we haven't
gotten like a good
it's like erotic thriller in a long time
you know it's been like many years I
know that they tried like fifty Shades
of Grey tried doing something but it
wasn't up to par yeah and then this one
though I'm like this looks like a sexy
dark thriller and it's nice to be like
yeah I remember those days of erotic
thriller is like when Michael Douglas
did like Basic Instinct and fatal
attraction you know Affairs gone wrong
those were very exciting films it's not
an affair rather it sounds like she was
jealous of the nanny yeah yeah I [ __ ]
up situation to be in
I didn't think the nanny was picking up
with her husband I thought here you're
soaking up like another guy yeah so
that's kind of confusing I was kind of
confused by what's going on with these
like yeah but tonally it looks creepy
and I feel like it's gonna be like it
just looks like a film that will put you
in kind of a psychological adventure yes
exactly exactly think of all the things
that you do that might be crazy to some
physical violence in their Chi like
Emily blows being dragged and that girl
got her hair pulled and a golf club like
you got a beautiful woman game beat I
don't like watching woman get beat like
I just really done I can't stand like
and moved I've seen movies where it's
like this woman just got her life she's
got beaten up and like this isn't like a
strong character already you know
there's two things I can't watch a
movies that and rape scenes like for
some reason rape scenes I'm always like
we didn't
really need to see the rape scene did we
sometimes it's arguable but I don't
think I could ever like I could get so
creative and so dark but I don't think
anyone ever want to throw in a rape
scene in the movie it's it's just a
little too present in current situations
and in current media and including
everyday lives of so many people to to
really throw it out there yeah just in a
movie like people throw the most common
things in movies and something like that
and I don't know but at the same time
you know I was an actor I can I
completely understand it's it's our job
to provide to portray real-life people
to portray we're alive cases and that is
with time putting people's real lives
and is you know unfortunately that is a
situation that happens to a lot of women
and a lot of men honestly not really
talked about enough but at the same time
you know it's not easy to watch yeah and
then also with like the spousal abuse in
here just with like your violence of
like hurting another hurting your
partner like that especially the one
like oh my god I can point like someone
you loved like or their hair or
something like it could be a turn-on in
bed though I took a left turn quickly
I can't incorrect the right amount of
pulling this is right turn
oh you're better no thank you no I'm not
turning to the bedroom unless is that
what's happening
no thank you thank you it's a
persistence whereas now resistance
people just got stay yeah I mean tonally
looks cool like the way it's shot to my
guy there's a lot to look forward to
here I like the cast and everything yeah
oh guys yeah get on the train that looks
like an exciting thriller um I'm gonna
watch that I love Emily blocking Emily
Blunt is an amazing actress she's so
beautiful she's she's a good classically
beautiful she is you ever smoke
cigarettes she does read this article on
Zurich net that was 20 actresses who
smoke cigarettes
I don't know 20 but Emily Blunt stood
out to me because I was like oh Emily
Blunt likes equal and opposite arete but
your whole this we are just sweet heart
please honey [ __ ] together Emily Blunt
you should be smoking weed the other
things listen guys if you're a girl on
the train or you're a guy in the in
front of the computer you can subscribe
to day and become a reject the cause
cancer rejects Caroline Gibson Mills is
someone who will fulfill your heart with
joy on her Instagram snapchat links in
description box and she started up a
YouTube channel more videos coming soon
so subscribe today so you can get
notified when those bad boys are out I
want to end this video on a shout out
this dude I met at the carnival named
Max he's a really dedicated fan to the
channel and Max I wanted to say hello to
you hopefully you did catch this video
too
you made my night by showing me love and
praise it was awkward that you came on
to me
afterwards and you just went for it you
just can't reach out like that man like
that was just really uncomfortable there
were people around your girlfriend got
upset I would kind of you know watch
your impulses a little bit next time
invite her
suggestions try to make everyone happy
thank you max for being dedicated love
and support we appreciate you and good
bye